STRETCH WILL BE TOMORROW IN
CHIPPED TO THE HEAD.
BUMPED BY LUCIC.
PUCK K ONE.
>> Cassie: TAGE THOMPSON WHO
LEADS THE B IT
DOWN AND LIFT THE PUCK INTO THE.
HANIFIN SHOOTS.
STOPPED BY
DUBE CHIPS IT IN.
THREE GOALS AWAY FROM
CONSISTENCY HE MIGHT GET MORE
ICE TIME.
>> Rick: ERRANT PASS.
TOKARSKI OUT TO PLAY AT CENTRE.
CHRIS TANEV IN HISAND MORE WAYS
INTERMISSION ABOUT WHERE HE
SHOULD PLAY.
YOU WANT HIM TO BE A  AWAY
CHRIS TANEV TAKES A LOOK.DEFENC.
HOW ABOUT
PENALTY IN THE FIRST POWER PLAY
FOR BUFFALO.
>> Cassi COZENS.
THAT WILL GO ALL THE A LITTLE BA
ROLLERCOASTER FROM A GOALTENDIN
MARKSTROM REALIZES HE HAS TO  O
THE NET.
TANEV PICKS IT OFF KIDDING ME?
>> Rick: HERE'S COZENS DOWN THE
WING.
FACE.
HAD TO BE SHARP HERE IN THE LAST
FEW   TO LUCIC.
TRYING TO SHAKE
TOKARSKI DIDN'T REALIZE THERE
WAS ON  AND THEAND IS ABLE TO C
>> Cassie: YOU THINK OF DARRYL
SUTTER WALL.
HE'S WATCHED BY LEWIS.
[ ♪ ]
>> Cassie: ANDREW MANGIAPANE HAD
A CHANCE SHORTHANDED.
ANDERSSON CONTROLS.H WITH A SHOH
ON MARKSTRO THE OTHER WAYAKES
JEFF SKINNER BACK TO THE LY ONE.
3-ON-3.
GAUDREAU, LINDHOLM, KYLINGTON B.
PUTS IT OUTSIDE HIS OWN HANGS O.
STOLEN BY GAUDREAU JUST OUT OF
HIS REACH.
LONG PASS.
MARKSTROM OUT TO